when i'm going through change in my life
or i have a specific outcome that i want
to create i love to get up early in the
morning that's my time i'm a 4 30 in the
morning guy because
that's my time the rest of the day i'm
serving but
i love getting up early and changing and
working and having some time to myself
and i believe that when i invest in
myself i invest in my future and that
time in my in my morning nobody bothers
me because that's my time
and because of brain waves and brain
chemistry
the door between the conscious mind and
the subconscious mind is more open
and so if i get up early and i'm kind of
between theta and alpha i don't have to
work as hard i'm not thinking i just
kind of relax into the moment
in the evening i always ask myself how
did i do
how was one lifetime in one day where
did i fall from grace what happened
and so
then when i look at seeing how i reacted
to someone or something or i made the
choice that i could have made a better
choice i naturally and we all do this
begin to think well if the same
situation happened again how would i do
it differently
and that's the act of beginning to come
up with a new plan
the act of rehearsing it in your mind
begins to install the circuits in your
brain priming your brain so that when
the next experience happens you could
modify your behavior to do a better job
in life that's called plasticity
so
it doesn't matter for me what meditation
i do any longer i like to just get up in
a new state of being i have people say
to me hey um
i miss my meditation today like i'm
supposed to go like this or something
and i say to them
eyes open our eyes closed
you know my eyes open our eyes closed
you know when you're passionate about
something
you know when people can't get up in the
morning and they can't get out of bed
i'm going to tell you why
because they can predict the feeling of
everything that's going to happen in
their life and their bodies resigned to
the familiar it says oh another mundane
day but remember when you were a kid and
you were going on a field trip
what happened then
you were up and dressed and ready to go
before your parents were up you know why
because you knew something unexpected
was going to happen that's how we should
live our lives waking up with the
understanding to expect the unexpected
and something unusual should happen in
our life as a result of our efforts and
it's just those beginning moments where
it begins to happen that we begin to
prove to ourselves how powerful we
really are so take time in the morning
in the evening and the rest of the day
check in with yourself at certain times
to see if you're still in that energy
and if you're not excuse yourself for a
second raise your energy and step back
into your life if you keep doing that
over and over again
you'll become less frustrated less
impatient less judgmental it'll just
become something of the past and you'll
be someone else
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how you can
manifest your success
enjoy
rule number two let go of doubt with
rhonda byrne i just want you to know
doubt this comes from the mind
and they're just thoughts and
and they're the reason that they're
appearing is because you have a belief
that is saying that you don't have this
already but just don't give those doubts
any any energy and work harder on
feeling that you have your manifestation
because when you believe you have your
manifestation no thoughts of doubt will
come when you believe you have it you
have overridden any other belief in the
subconscious mind you've reprogrammed
your subconscious and then it will
manifest so
just remind yourself that you are the
power
that creates everything
effortlessly effortlessly
you with that power so so just
take it it's not it's not an effort it's
really easy
you know it's it's really easy just take
it easy
let go of the let go of the doubtful
thoughts rule number three reprogram
your paradigm with bob proctor we have
here in the subconscious the paradigm
and part of the paradigm
with respect
to money
is
it's a poverty thing
now this paradigm
impacts our thinking there's a power
flowing into our consciousness
and the thoughts we think
are generally
motivated by the subconscious mind
now something that i've been
pointing out here recently
on look at this
the subconscious mind is universal
intelligence
so when you have that paradigm in the
subconscious mind
that controls the vibration that we're
in
and the vibration we're in is going to
dictate what we attract because we're in
that vibration here on a conscious level
on a subconscious level and on a
physical so you're going to attract from
anywhere you go in the universe the same
type of thing that's that's what we're
attracting
so we're attracting people that are in
harmony with this and this paradigm
causes our thinking to be along the same
level
now
we've got to realize even in our
ignorance when we don't know and we
haven't got anything our thinking is
hooked into universal intelligence
and you will attract from wherever it is
in the universe whatever is required
to cause the problem when you hear
people say you know i just get one
filled bill paid and another one pops up
bang they're gonna attract it
and sure as it gets dark they get it
now that's ingrained in our mind from
the time we're children
in fact
from the moment of conception in most of
us
and then we grow into it and that's what
we hear is we're growing up money
doesn't grow on trees and and over and
over you can't have everything you want
you know
and
that is uh
that's got to be eliminated
and we've got to realize that is not
fact
that you do not have to work harder
that you do less
and you earn more
and you've got to get the idea that you
can have money coming in from many
different places in the world dragging
it right into you
you attract it
and you can magnetize yourself
to money
in all different quantities
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four create new
affirmations with john assaraf when you
want to override automatic negative
thoughts or disempowering you know
beliefs
or self-image issues the first thing you
want to do from a brain
perspective
is first
acknowledge that hey i have this
disempowering thought or disempowering
image a self-image or disempowering fear
i acknowledge that that's okay so the
first thing you do is you don't pretend
it doesn't exist because your brain
knows it exists you notice it the dog
knows it exists
but when you take that
and say yes that's true and now i'm
going to create a new vision for what i
want
to feel i'm going to create a new vision
for how i want to see myself i'm going
to create a new vision to
see myself at the level
above the level that i'm at right now
and you create an image and write it
down
and then what you can do is you can
create a new powerful declaration or
affirmation that goes like this you may
want to write this down okay and it's
just a beginning process of retraining
your brain there's there's six different
steps that you can do here i'll give you
two of them so you create a declaration
and you say
even though
i feel or even though i have this belief
of
what i
am focusing on now
is
my augmented self-worth or self-esteem
what i'm focusing on now is getting
smarter wiser what i'm focusing on now
is releasing this fear and stepping into
my confidence and my certainty now a
simple
little declaration of acceptance and
then moving towards what you want
that starts to activate a new neural
pattern so you don't have to lie to
yourself and say you know
for example is if you feel like you're
not smart enough not worthy
not capable and you say you know in the
past i have felt that i wasn't smart
enough not worthy not capable and now
i'm learning how to
if you could just create a bridge from
the disempowering thought or belief or
emotion or behavior and you can create a
bridge to where the next step is and now
i'm learning how to and now i'm taking
steps towards
when you give yourself that bridge your
brain goes okay you can do this
so if you don't want to go from i'm not
smart enough to i'm really smart and i
could achieve it for some people that's
too big of a jump so create a bridge
between those two so that you reduce the
neural tension and you're nice to your
brain
and that is one of the ways that you can
do that rule number five focus on
serving with lewis howes if you are in a
tough financial spot maybe you're
struggling financially you've been
trying to start a business or a side
hustle
i've been there i know what this feels
like it's not fun for a long time i was
living on my sister's couch and i didn't
have much money it was really stressful
i remember this feeling of being stuck
feeling like i was never going to make
any money and when i was focusing on
that feeling of i'm never going to make
this money i feel stuck i feel trapped
when's this going to happen feeling this
anxiousness this stress around it
it was really impossible for me to think
of creative ideas it was impossible for
me to
take action because i was living in the
stress as opposed to the gratitude for
what i was having in that moment i
should have been focusing on you know
what my sister is allowing me to stay
here for free so i have some time to
learn a new skill
i made a hundred dollars this day i
should be grateful for that not focusing
on what i'm lacking or what i don't have
but what i am creating on a daily basis
and i started to ask different questions
around this time like how can i be of
service to other people how can i add as
much value to someone else or what are
my top skill sets that i can use
to my advantage that no one else has
like what do i have i started writing a
list of all these different skills that
i had even when i didn't think i had
many skills i still wrote down a list of
the qualities i have of the skills from
the past that maybe i could apply to
right now and when i began asking those
types of questions i started attracting
the people who needed my skill sets and
services and i finally started to make
more money than ever before because i
was thinking about serving others i was
thinking from a positive grateful
standpoint about helping others and
starting a side hustle which turned into
a business instead of thinking
negatively about not having any money or
i'm sleeping on my sister's couch and
why is it taking me so long to create
this and i'll never make anything from
this situation i started focusing on how
can i add value as much value as
possible to this one person in front of
me right now how can i serve them how
can i create for them how can i connect
someone to them that could help them
what can i do to add value and help
someone else achieve their goals because
i think as zig ziglar said if you want
to accomplish all of your goals help
other people accomplish their goals and
that's what i started focusing on not
what i'm lacking but how can i give and
how can i add value to other people when
you focus outward on service you start
to really attract some incredible things
in your life it's unbelievable the
ripple effect the domino effect one
person helping another person how it
comes back around to you and if you've
ever felt this for yourself leave a
comment below of this feeling you've had
when you started adding more and more
value getting out of the negative
situation inside your mind and in your
body and focusing outward on helping
others it's incredible the things you
can start to attract and manifest in
your life rule number six commit to
positive self-talk with brendon burchard
every
day that self-talk commands you to be
congruent with the best of who you are
and the more you are congruent the more
you are fulfilled
you can do fulfilling things but if you
are incongruent you don't feel fulfilled
think about that because your mind your
body your spirit knows
if you're being congruent if you are a
person of integrity living the best life
if the further you are away from that
the harder it is to be fulfilled even if
you're doing fulfilling things like
serving people
so get your self-talk realigned i can't
emphasize anymore how important it is to
master this area of your life
to take control to create a consistent
routine of positive self-talk that
guides you towards being your best
every day
so that you have more opportunities
you're gonna have lots of misses but
because you're stepping at the plate
you'll have more swings you'll have more
opportunities to hit a home run you have
more opportunities to have the at-bat to
be your best self and the more that you
do that the more hits you get
the more hits you get the better you
feel the more competent and capable and
so i'm encouraging you all to please
please please remember this
say amazing things to yourself have an
affirmation list have a practice do it a
certain time a certain date certain in
my world
i you know i'm blessed to run with the
greatest motivational speakers of our
time
and
all of them all of them
have something they say to themselves
backstage before they go out on stage
do they need to do that
no
yes
if they don't see they're commanding
themselves they're willing themselves
they're encouraging themselves if you
don't like the word command or demand
they're encouraging themselves to get
into the right state of mind to have
their best performance their best
service so that later on they can go
that was really great i appreciate that
i feel good about that i feel fulfilled
see it's hard to feel fulfilled if you
don't feel good about how you showed up
when you feel good about how you show up
again and again and again and again the
senses of meaning and fulfillment
lift up and rule number seven the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is boost your self-worth with marissa
peer millionaires and people who have
incredible wealth
leave clues there are seven things that
you can do
to attract wealth into your life and you
can start right now number one is
examine your relationship with money
because you do have a relationship with
money do you worry about it slipping
through your fingers do you hold on to
it are you scared of spending when you
tip only a tiny amount because you
really haven't got enough and you're in
that scarcity mindset
look at how you hold on to money how you
worry do you say things like
i can't find the money which in itself
is kind of weird because nobody finds
money do you say money slips through my
fingers i can't hold on to money when
you examine these expressions
they're not even true
so look at how you talk about money how
you feel about money boost your
self-worth by saying things like i
deserve money
i'm worth money i have an amazing skill
set i deserve to monetize this gift i've
got i have a gift
and i can monetize what i can do create
is worth financial investment so don't
think things like i'm going to write a
book no one's going to read it i'm going
to open a shop nobody will come do the
opposite i have a phenomenal product
everyone's going to fall in love with
this product
i'm monetizing a gift and if i believe
in it so much because it's worth
believing in so will everyone else
commit
to achieving financial abundance i've
just been in someone else's documentary
about how to become an entrepreneur
how to make money yourself it has never
been easier there are so many youtube
tutorials
an instagram post where you can find out
how to create wealth how to create a
product how to sell a product how to be
good at selling
good at finding funding good at
promoting something you have for
instance do you want to write a book
i've just written my seventh book you've
got to be really good at promoting a
book it's not enough to write a great
book not even maybe you have to learn
how to
promote that book write articles about
your book go on shows and blogs and talk
about your books if you want something
you're gonna have to learn something
anything of significance that you want
will require you learning something new
like marketing for instance and if you
can learn marketing
you can make a lot of money by marketing
an amazing product even if it's not your
product be productive not busy you can
get more done
in less time when you focus it's so easy
to go i'm going to write a book let me
sharpen my pencils do some spell check
get everything just right just get on
with it
sit down and focus on what you're doing
you can get more done in less time when
you just narrow your thoughts down
wealth is also a state of mind you see
you can be a generous person generous
with your time
generous with compliments generous with
help don't think i haven't got any money
and so
i can't really go to this place i've got
to turn up with gifts or i'm poor don't
have a poor mentality have a generous
mentality give a lot of yourself and
when you can give
a lot of yourself you can get so much
back people who are wealthy give more
you know and i'm working with a client i
don't go oh sorry time's up now i let
time run over
i give more i do more
giving more and doing more than is
required of you will make you destined
for success but do it because you love
it not because you think oh i need to
stay at the office late i need to spend
more time with this customer they don't
really deserve it but i've got to give
give give it's not that kind of giving
when you give more and do more remember
you
they remember you and they want to give
more back to you
the fastest way to change your habits is
to change your environment
you ever notice how when you're in a
different environment maybe you go on
vacation maybe you go to an event or
seminar
you start doing different things you are
still you and you do some of the things
that you used to do but all of a sudden
you're doing new things that become a
part of your regular routine you ever
been away for a couple weeks and
discover that you built up some new
habits and maybe some are healthy maybe
some are unhealthy
but if you've ever been away and you
notice that you've picked up some new
habits why was because the environment
demanded it because everybody else was
doing it because it was so easy natural
comfortable to do that that that's why
you do it too and so if you want to be
able to switch your habits quickly you
change your environments now you may not
always be able to go on vacation or go
to events or seminars so those those are
options but it starts with you figuring
out well what are
the habits that you want to develop who
are the people that you want to be
around and when you are around those
people you will start to think
differently which will lead to you
behaving differently when you see other
people doing it you're going to want to
do it more when it's in your environment
more you're going to want to do it more
too this morning i was talking to a
youtuber big youtuber bigger than me
more subscribers than me slightly
different niche and i remember meeting
him in california
a couple years ago and one of the things
he was struggling with was staying
consistent
and i'm very consistent
and one of the things i was struggling
with was staying healthy while i was on
the road and we were having dinner
together and he was eating
super clean he was eating fish and salad
and i probably had a burger or something
fries and
coming away from that what i realized
was
whoever is more confident wins
and when you're around other people
whoever's more confident in the habit
that they have
will be the dominant habit that both of
you end up picking up so if we were
hanging out together more here's what
would happen i would become a lot
healthier in my eating and he would
become a lot more consistent in his
content because we'd be inspired by each
other because he'd see me where can we
make my videos and he'd feel bad that he
was making his and he'd have to go and
start making his and i see him eating
healthy all the time and be like man i
should be eating healthy and they would
force me to do it as well
that environment switch would allow us
to create much better stronger habits so
now you got to be careful about
the kind of people who you're hanging
out with and if you look at the people
you've got right now around you
chances are
they're keeping you stuck they're
keeping you small they're keeping you
where you are and you're probably
pouring into them right you're the one
giving them love giving them
encouragement giving them support
pouring into them you're taking your cup
and pouring into them and it's great and
it's and you should keep doing that and
it's amazing and it it's fulfilling
but who's pouring into you and who's
making you get to the next step uh
because if you don't have that you're
gonna you're gonna continue to stay
small or just have slow growth compared
to where you could be so
how do we get some practical steps okay
that's great what do we actually do how
do you start making that change happen
well the first step is to figure out
what is it that you want to get better
at you know what area of your life or
business do you want to be better at
is it you want to stay more consistent
on your habits you want to you want to
learn how to make money you want to have
a better relationship you want to take
care of your health like what is the
thing that you actually want to get
better on getting clarity on what that
thing is two is to then surround
yourself as much as possible with
with content not even people because it
could be great to say hey awesome hang
around joe dispenz all the time and you
will
you will become better you will meditate
more you will solve your awesome but you
don't know joe dispenza and he's
probably not taking on students right
now or mentees right or elon musk or
oprah winfrey whoever right you don't
know them and so that's not a practical
answer but you can hang around their
content it's why i make these videos
every day because if every day there was
a new video for you hopefully it lifts
you to bring some of the best experts in
the world
the people that i find inspiring and
learn from to share their message
every morning you don't have that person
in your life but there's videos for you
so step two is step one we're figuring
out what is it that we want right where
do we wanna improve and get better step
two is who are the people who are who
are living it who are preaching it who
are living it who actually inspire you
and
there's so many different people out
there who are doing it and everybody has
their own way i'd like to say that you
know and eric thomas is going to yell at
you through it and oprah winfrey is
going to hug you through it but they
have very similar messages
whoever's style you connect with the
most
have that more consistently in your
environment follow them on instagram
subscribe to them on youtube put their
quotes on the wall around you create
your own environment of the people who
make you
feel like you want to do more
who inspire you to step out of your
comfort zone and take on those new
habits that you want to actually adopt
right so you're creating a new
environment for yourself without having
to go live with joe dispenza or elon
musk or oprah winfrey
okay so i call them aspirational mentors
and that can be fundamental and that's
where most people need to start
because you have access to their books
and their videos and their content you
have that access right now and that can
make a big shift in you if you start
surrounding yourself with it every day
and then step three is to is to get more
in-person connections and this is more
time-consuming and more challenging and
harder to find the right fits but
can make a big shift as well in your
life so
i don't want to only rely on that's why
step two is actually having just content
that you're learning from but step three
if there's people that you're learning
from do they have an event do they have
something coming up can you hang around
people who are
like-minded who are also taking on
challenges i'm doing a challenge right
now inside my movement makers program
where
moviemakers is for thought leaders who
are trying to get to the next level with
their content and break through and have
a greater message and reach more people
but a lot of people haven't been as
consistent as they should have um
because they're the only ones doing this
they don't know anybody else making
content their family thinks they're
crazy like why are you making another
video they're not seeing results they
don't have a peer group they don't have
anybody to connect with and talk to and
this can relate to any goal that you
have movement makers is just for kind of
thought leaders making content but
whatever goal that you have if you're
the only one that you know who's doing
it it's really hard to stay consistent
on it so our movement maker's challenge
is every month we have a challenge where
you have to make a lead magnet for your
business a solo video and then three
collaboration videos with other people
in the group so it forces you to
start making content and for a lot of
the members this is the most consistent
they've ever been now in making content
because one they're doing it together
you feel like you're doing it with other
people even though
a lot of the content that you make um
outside will still be separate from the
members you're not doing a business
together but it feels like they're
connected we're taking on this challenge
together and then in the collaboration
videos you're you're connecting with
people you're doing interviews with
people you're you're sharing your
thoughts and feedback it's not just you
talking to a camera in the car with your
dogs by yourself anymore
and that really really really really
matters it really matters so getting
some kind of support group connecting
with other people who are on the same
journey going to seminars or events
of of humans that you can talk to and
connect with who are doing the thing
that you want to do because the more
that you're around those people the more
you're going to stay consistent on the
habits that you want to build so using
that three-step process can absolutely
change your life
it's it's entirely possible and if
you're watching videos like this you're
you're already on the growth mindset
journey right you're already into
personal development you already know
you want to do more and serve more and
help more and this helps you elevate
yourself to the next level because
you are probably the most
ambitious person that you know that
you're hanging out with and and that's a
great place to be because you're serving
and helping but it also sucks because it
limits your growth of what you could
become where if you can
one clearly identify what do you want to
change what is the habit that you want
to take on where are you not satisfied
anymore in your life not beating
yourself up and saying you suck but like
the next level of growth that you want
to accomplish for yourself and then two
following people just through content
who are living that message
who are who are not just
speaking it but live in it who who when
you watch their their videos you
actually get inspired to go make a
change in your life who are those people
subscribe to them follow them every day
watch their content read their books put
their stuff up on your wall as a
reminder you're creating a new
environment for yourself and then three
is actually connecting with humans
joining a group like movement makers or
something else going to events where
your your tribe is at so that you are
not alone doing this journey feeling
isolated and like you don't belong
make those three changes it will change
your life the difference between where
you are now where you could be it's just
the consistent habits that you're
putting in you know this i know you know
this
now it's about taking the actual action
to stay consistent on those habits think
of this for a moment
do you know that every living soul gets
exactly the same amount of time
exactly the same amount of time
figure it out
you get all there is
a hobo sleeping under a bridge or on a
park bench
that has no material possessions
none
does nothing of any
constructive nature
that person gets exactly the same amount
of time as the most
productive industrialist in the world
we all get exactly the same amount of
time so it's what we do with the time
that makes a difference
i want you to think of the number of
time management programs almost everyone
under the sun has time management
programs
in fact i made one one time spent a lot
of money on it
and then i found out it was a dumb waste
of time and money
do you know why
time can't be managed i was having
breakfast with earl nightingale one
morning
and it was downtown chicago
and i was going with him on his speaking
engagement
and it was early in the morning he said
you want to meet for breakfast
whenever earl nigel said you want to
meet me i was there and i always had
some well-prepared questions and i
remember asking him i said
how did you learn how to master time
management you know we're having
breakfast i can still hear his fork hit
the plate he's what the hell are you
talking about
he's i've never mastered time management
nobody masters time management he said
time can't be managed
because i merely manage activity
and he took a little card out of his
pocket
and he said every night before i go to
bed i write down six most important
things i have to do tomorrow these are
goal achieving activities and when i
wake up that's what i start working on
and if i don't get them all done i'll
add them to tomorrow's list
you should have about six
now if i have three that i didn't get
done today that doesn't mean i have nine
for tomorrow like six plus these three
those three become part of the six you
have to do the next day
[Music]
when you wake up
you give all your conscious attention to
do those things see you cannot manage
time
but you can manage activity
you can manage your activities
make certain that what you're doing
really makes a difference makes certain
that you're spending your time on
activities that are productive that are
taking you in the direction of your goal
the thoughts we think and the words we
speak are constantly shaping our world
and our experiences
many of us are in an old habit of
negative thinking and do not realize the
damage we have inflicted upon ourselves
however we are never stuck
because we can always change our
thinking
as we learn to consistently choose
positive thoughts the old negative ones
dissolve away
so as you listen to the following power
thoughts
let the affirmations and ideas wash over
your consciousness
your subconscious mind will pick up the
ones that are important to you at the
moment
these concepts are like fertilizing the
soil of your mind
as you absorb them by repetition you are
slowly enriching the very basis of your
garden of life anything you plant will
grow abundantly
i see you vibrant and healthy
surrounded by exquisite beauty
living a life of love and prosperity
filled with joy and laughter
you are on a wonderful pathway of change
and growth
enjoy your trip
[Music]
my healing is already in process
your body knows how to heal itself
get the negative garbage out of the way
then love your body
feed it nourishing foods and beverages
pamper it respect it create an
atmosphere of wellness allow yourself to
heal the reason why you are not chasing
your big dream is because you are afraid
that it's going to fail you're afraid
that it's not going to work and what
people will say about you and what you
will think about yourself but what's the
alternative it's sitting on your idea
for years never taking your shot because
you're afraid and living the rest of
your life in regret knowing that you had
an opportunity but were too afraid to
take it the way to not have regrets is
to be always taking action to as soon as
you get an idea go do something about it
i had a great podcast with my friend
mark drager uh a couple weeks ago a
month ago or so where
he was asking me about regret and i used
to always tell this story of imagine you
have a hangnail how much that hurts and
it's all you can think about when you
have a hangnail but if somebody punches
you in the arm you don't feel the
hangnail anymore because
this hurts more right you focus on what
hurts more and suddenly this one doesn't
hurt as much that's how i would use
regret i would always think about
whatever pain that i'm in right now this
thing that i want to do but i'm afraid i
would imagine that this thing is going
to be the best thing of all time that
this video i'm going to make this speech
i'm going to give this clan i'm going to
make is going to be the best of all time
and if i don't do it i'm going to regret
it for the rest of my life for decades
i'm going to regret not taking action
and so
the pain of doing the thing is the hang
nail and the future pain of regret for
decades is the punch to the arm and so
it inflicts so much pain on me that then
i have to go off and do that thing and i
use that for
[Music]
over a decade
over a decade that's the lens through
which i made decisions and saw the world
but for the past two years i haven't
done that at all i haven't talked about
it i haven't
done it for myself because i talk about
the things that i live
and i'm thinking why why don't i do that
anymore why don't i use future regret to
fuel me
and i found this because i'm always
taking action because as soon as i get
an idea i do something and so i don't
judge the idea i don't say why me i
don't ponder on the idea i don't i don't
just default to strategizing and
thinking i don't think why did i come up
with this why am i thinking about this i
just do it you get an idea you go off
and do it and that's been my mindset for
the past year and a half two years and
as a result
the breakthrough was
you don't live with regret
if you're always taking action on the
ideas that you have you don't live with
regret you might regret some of the
things you end up doing but most of the
things that you regret and other things
done as the actions undone
not undone not taken the action is not
taken you don't regret the things that
you did you get the things that you
didn't do that's most people right there
may be a couple things that you regret
that you did but for the most part it's
the things that you are too afraid to do
that you regret for the rest of your
life and so if you're constantly doing
if you're constantly taking action if
you're always jumping then you don't
have regrets
and it's been an interesting way that i
now see the world and hopefully you can
learn from as soon as you get an idea
you go off and you do something you do
that you won't have any regrets there's
a primary law called the law of
vibration
the law of vibration decrees that
everything in this universe moves
nothing rests
the body in a coffin is moving
probably you're probably thinking this
guy's smoking something like if the body
in a coffin wasn't moving how would it
ever change to dust
it's always moving it's always vibrating
everything vibrates we live in a notion
of motion take a microscope and look at
a solid wall it's not solid it only
appears to be solid or perception
problem there you'll see the wall moving
right in front of your eyes there's a
particle of energy and they're dancing
right before your eyes that's a lot of
vibration the law of vibration decrees
everything moves nothing rests we
literally live in a notion of motion
now this physical instrument we're
living in we call our body is a
molecular structure and it's in a very
high speed of vibration
our brain is an electronic switching
station when we activate brain cells we
alter the vibration in different parts
of the body i could not move my hand up
and down or my arm up and down without
first giving a message to my brain to do
that
well the brain
activates cells in the body it sets up a
vibration in the body
the
vibration that the mind and body are in
is going to dictate what you attract
because when you put yourself in a
vibration what you're really doing is
put yourself on a specific frequency
that's what you do when you set a goal
most people set a goal and then wait for
it to happen and never going to happen
you've got to assume that it's already
happened you've got a picture of it in
your mind mentally it's already happened
it's happened because i've got the idea
in my conscious mind if i didn't have
the idea of my conscious mind i couldn't
talk to you about it the very fact i can
talk to you about it means that i've
already got it
then i've got to get emotionally
involved in it
i'm already emotionally involved in the
goal that i've got i've got it
intellectually i've got it emotionally
it's only a period of time till it moves
into form how does it move into form
well you attract whatever is required
for it to move into form you attract all
the energy that's necessary to produce
the physical result how do you do that
you do that by intellectually
emotionally staying in the vibration
of the good that you desire you see it
already in the present tense so that
keeps you on the frequency
and that frequency then dictates what
you're going to attract you can only
attract to you
what's in harmonious vibration with you
now if you're holding an image that you
can't get something you're on a
vibration
you're not going to get it but if you
can see yourself with it you know it's
coming to you you know it you know it's
only a period of time you're not quite
sure what the time is but you know it's
a period of time and bang that thing's
going to manifest in your life
you have controlled the vibration that
you're in
the vibration then called the frequency
you put yourself in the frequency that
you good your desires on let's suppose i
want to have a lot of money we're just
talking about money now this is a lot of
money relative to let's say
this there's one 100 here's 10 100 100.
so one's a lot relative to the other
neither one is a lot it just is
if i want to attract a lot of my i got
to see myself with a lot of money i got
to mentally accept i've already got it i
don't let my bank account dictate that i
choose that
so i'm choosing myself to see myself
with the good i already desire i'm on
that frequency now the trick is to stay
on that frequency
most people look at the results and they
let the results dictate the frequency
they're on that's why they keep getting
the same results
they have the image in their mind
they're already reached the goal they
want they're already successful and
somebody else comes along and say well
you haven't got those results
in my mind i have but they're not
looking in my mind they're looking at my
present results and then pretty soon i
start listening to them i think god
they're right i look at my results i
haven't got it you see why we keep
getting this poor results
you've got to see yourself with the good
you desire you've got to hold that image
in your mind you've got to know it's
going to come and that will attract
everything that's necessary see nothing
is created or destroyed everything's
already here if done in one frequency
certainly in another or not in one state
certainly in another we've got to get on
the frequency of the good that we desire
eighty percent of you who use a vision
book or a vision board say it changed me
i've told you about my vision board i
had it above my bed i wanted to get
married i wanted to go to africa and
here's a picture of my wedding was such
a here's a picture of me in africa
holding a lion that had been raised
macabre with a family and it lived there
and it was amazing but i made these come
true i had that vision in my mind i held
that vision i'm
getting married i'm going on safari
and you're never given a vision without
an idea of making it real because what
you want wants you
what you are moving towards is moving
towards you have a vision or a dream or
a wish inside you
get it out of you
put it on paper look at it touch it
read it then you are making it real when
you can look at your vision right all
over your vision
write on it change it mix it up it's not
a dream
you're making it real your potential
expands as you move towards it this will
expand your potential
when you move your mind to a new
dimension it never moves back
never right i wish i dream right i am i
do i can i will i always
i always exercise i can
fit exercise into my life i am
a fit person
i always pick healthy food i can find
healthy food wherever i go i'm the kind
of person that makes eating well a
master priority i can i do i am i always
inspire your mind turn it on with
exciting words turn it on the other
thing about this vision book is it makes
you accountable as you look every day at
the pictures of someone doing yoga
or eating fruit you think well
i better stop looking at that and start
doing it every day as you look at
pictures somebody working from home
socializing looking after their body
horse riding
hiking
making salads as you look at it enough
you become inspired
to take action it motivates you it
inspires you it fills up your mind with
what you want
and it fills you up with a desire a
passion
it motivates you conditions you programs
you compels you to go after what you
want
it holds you accountable
and it's so easy
so don't make it perfect there's a
process which has made more people rich
than any other single process of goals
achieving
and it's to take your major goal and
structure it as a question if your goal
is to earn 100 000 a year then you write
how can i earn 100 000
in the next 12 months that's an
open-ended question not how can i earn
it at my job or doing a specific thing
just an open-ended question how can i
earn the amount of money and then you
discipline yourself to write 20 answers
to the question
and the 20 answers are all the different
things that you could think of to earn a
hundred thousand dollars work a longer
work harder upgrade my skills
get a new job take a part-time
opportunity
whatever it happens to be write down
everything you could think of but force
yourself to write at least 20 questions
or 20 answers to the question
the 20 question method called
mindstorming forces you to dig deep deep
into your mind
where you will find all your answers and
it may be call a person uh read a book
let me give you an example uh we had a
young fellow entrepreneur he got 35
years old he built a successful business
he worked about 10 years to do it and he
for two years wanted to sell his
business so he could take a year off and
travel enjoy his money
and so for two years he just sort of
floundered around like a fish on the
dock wanting to sell his business nobody
uh
offered to buy it he suggested it to
people people were not interested and so
on and in this exercise that they put
him through his 20th answer and often
it's the 20th answer that is the
breakthrough was
buy a book on how to sell your own
business
and it just went off like a flash bulb
in his mind at the break he got up as a
downtown hotel got up went down the
street to a major bookstore went and
found he was amazed at the number of
books had been written on how to buy and
sell a business so he bought two or
three books two months later he had
restructured packaged his business sold
it completely satisfactorily and took a
year off
he said it was just a single idea it was
a breakthrough idea but it was so simple
just get a book on the subject and you
think boy that's pretty obvious yes but
it's the most obvious answers that we
overlook i am a powerful manifester you
have to meet the vibration you can't be
above or below it it's just what i was
talking about negative energy
positive energy in order to draw the
thing to you that you want to come you
can't want it so much that you fear that
you won't get it you have to want it so
in order for me to be on your vision
board you must have put it there and
then you let it go yes and then you
weren't thinking about it every day
every day every day because you can't it
doesn't come to you that way you have to
do it and you have to put it and then
you have to meet that vibration you
prepare yourself to be there and ready
there is a reason many of the great
women and men of the world the great
history makers the great poets the great
philosophers the great
movement makers rose before the sun
there is a magic in the air at 5 a.m and
that's why the 5am club is so
transformational because it's the time
of greatest quietude and i believe
tranquility is the new luxury on our
planet it is the time of intimate
creativity because you've just been
rested your brain is fresh there's
there's latest
there's there's very recent cutting-edge
science coming out now when you sleep
your brain actually has a mechanism to
wash itself when you wake up in the
morning your willpower is strongest when
you wake up in the morning you've got a
full well of mental focus and we know
that focus in our world is even more
valuable than intelligence and i could
go on and on on the benefits i mean you
get up at 5 00 a.m you've got the world
to yourself there's no crowds you can
think you can plan you can care for
yourself in a world where so many people
are so depleted and so the five it the 5
am club really is a game changer and
then it's not just get up at 5 a.m and
you know scratch your stomach or stare
up at the ceiling or look at your phone
or look at especially i believe you can
play with your phone or change the world
you don't get to do both yeah and so uh
it the 5m club method is based on the 20
20 20 formula i'm happy to get into it
but that is what it is that's the
revolutionizer and and it started from
my experience with working with many
billionaires i i've coached many of the
most successful financiers and
titans of industry for for over two
decades
and one of the things i would run them
through is the way you begin your day
sets up the way you live your day and so
the 20 20 20 formula that the book is
based upon is pretty simple i i go into
great detail in the book but
essentially it's from 5 to 5 20 the
first pocket is move
and i'm a fanatic about neuroscience and
why do you get up and move because
you're going to release serotonin which
is going to make you feel better you're
going to release dopamine which is the
pleasure and inspirational
neurotransmitter you're going to release
norepinephrine which will boost your
focus you'll promote neurogenesis marie
you can actually grow new brain cells
you'll increase your metabolic rate so
the way you beg the way you feel when
you first wake up is not the way you're
going to feel at 5 20. second pocket of
the 20 20 20 formula 20 minutes from 5
20 to 5 40 that's on reflection so a lot
of us are busy but what's the point of
being busy if you're doing the wrong
things
the the billionaires the great creatives
the people of great impact the people
who live beautiful lives are very
intentional they're very deliberate
they're very conscious so for 20 minutes
you write in a journal
you can visualize you can pray you can
meditate you can simply
contemplate how you're going to live
your day who what you want to stand for
during the day for example and then the
final pocket of the 20 20 20 formula is
all about grow and that's where you you
just read from a biography or a business
book or a philosophy book or a watching
marietv well especially watching tv yeah
of course that's the game changer isn't
it and so that's 20 minutes of growing
because i think we're most alive when we
are growing yes and um i believe the
leader who learns the most wins
manifesting is acquiring the experience
of what it is that you want to feel and
being and living and believing in that
experience and then allowing that
experience to come into form sometimes
we manifest things far beyond our
wildest dreams so sometimes if we have a
vision of something it happens in a far
greater way so we want to stay open yep
so we can say i want that macbook air
but maybe we get that macbook air that's
a little bit bigger than we thought yeah
or maybe it comes with an extra little
gift yeah but allowing ourselves to be
open this or something more manifesting
is very creative it is the process of
using your power energy and being in
that presence of your high-powered
energy and allowing that energy to
co-create with the energy that's around
you so you're vibrating at a high
frequency i'm vibrating at high
frequency we've done a lot of work we've
cleaned up a lot of our own crap we
believe in ourselves today and that that
energy of believing in ourselves has
attracted us together today and brought
us into this space where we together are
co-creating and teaching if i hadn't
cleaned up my side of the street if i
didn't believe in myself the way i do i
would never have manifested being on
marietv miracles occur naturally and
when they're not occurring something has
gone wrong
that's interesting it's a good one right
so what happens is that that
synchronicity that flow that effortless
action that just sort of allowing oh i
was thinking about that and it just
showed up that's how life is supposed to
be
we get in the way our negative belief
systems our fears our
anxiety our our anger towards the past
that future tripping and projecting all
of that energy gets in the way of
allowing all of the miracles to occur
naturally the first type of
manifestation is to get very very clear
you must be clear because if you are
unclear you'll start to call in some
things that are not really what you want
you'll be confused uh the other piece is
that once you're clear you can also then
get clear about all the ways that you
don't believe caught and thinking
negatively about the world and about
yourself this is so important
what would change inside of you if you
looked around
and you wrote down five things that
you're grateful for about the world now
this for me
is part of the secret to the law of
attraction it's the foundation is
gratitude it's your way of being must be
grateful in order to attract new things
there's so many things in my life that i
should not have attracted
because i didn't have the skills because
i didn't have the tools because i didn't
have the education because i didn't have
the money because i didn't have the
resources
so many things that i shouldn't have
attracted but because i had the
foundation of gratitude
passion joy curiosity those things
started to come to me and they can come
to you as well if you come from that
place of gratitude as your foundation
so you want to think about what are
these things that are important to me in
my life you know it can be simple things
it could be like this cup of coffee that
i have right now it can be that i have a
roof over my head that i've got quality
friends that i'm healthy
you know that i'm walking in nature
today it doesn't have to be
some grandiose thing that's happened to
you to be grateful for i'm so grateful
for these little present moments
with people that i care about to spend
an hour on the beach to go for a walk
with a friend to have a good
conversation with someone and talk about
something that i'm going through for me
that's just as meaningful
the moments in between the big moments
are just as meaningful so write down
these things or think about these things
this is something i embed in my daily
life when i wake up i think about what
i'm grateful for when i go to sleep i i
think about and reflect on the things
i'm grateful for from that day and it's
just my way of being for as much as i
can now i'm not perfect i make mistakes
and there's some times i'm negative
but it's something that i try to really
focus on as much as possible so instead
of saying that you're not enough
that you don't deserve success what if
you looked in the mirror on a daily
basis i dare you to look in the mirror
on a daily basis and say i am enough and
i do deserve
the results that i want to create in my
life because i show up because i'm
consistent because i work hard because i
care about my work
if you looked in the mirror and you did
this consistently for 30 days and you
actually
use the word action in attraction and
you put it into practice on a daily
basis towards that growth
i'd be amazed to see what you attract
and what you manifest in your life many
of us have issues with productivity
maybe we are overly productive but we're
feeling burnt out all the time or we're
not productive at all because we don't
know where to start
i found personally being in business for
myself for the last 20 years that i have
been a little overly productive i almost
did too much and i was constantly
multitasking and making things happen
and just moving so fast that ultimately
i really burnt out and i started feeling
brain fog i was feeling disoriented i
couldn't focus i was feeling like even
though i for so many years was priding
myself on the fact that i could get so
much done at one time i actually don't
think i was being nearly as productive
as i could have been so i hit a bottom
recently with this productivity overload
and i realized that i had to change my
patterns i had to change my ways i was
then blessed i said a prayer i said i
need some help with my brain fog and i
need some help with my productivity
issue and i that day got an email from
the dr oz show asking me to come on and
do a segment with this lovely author and
doctor dr mike dao and me and mike had
been in touch many years um for many
years just because he hadn't been an
author we were published by the same
publishers and mike had written a book
about brain fog so that day i'm like
thank you universe you're giving me
exactly what i need i go on dr oz with
mike and i'm backstage with him and i'm
like listen i'm feeling so
chaotic and i'm multitasking so much and
my i feel like i've got brain fog and
i'm forgetting things and he looked at
me says how much are you doing at one
time and i said oh mike i'm doing a
million things at once i have a thousand
tabs up on my screen and he's like these
are big brain no-no's and they're also
productivity no-no's is what he said
because he said that the more i try to
do and the more i try to multitask the
less i'm actually getting done so he
gave me a tip that i want to share with
you that has changed everything for me
and his suggestion was to just do five
things a day
to make a list of the five most
important things that i need to do that
day and not do number two until i've
completed number one and then once i
complete number one move on to number
two then on to number three and if i
don't get through all five in one day
i'll just pick up the fifth the next day
or wherever i left off i'll pick up the
next day
and to really stick to that list and not
move back and forth and not try to make
a million other things added on to that
list and just be really committed to
that five task list
i did it i started to just be very clear
about the five things i was doing in a
day i told my team i made a a list in my
base camp which is where we keep all of
our notes and i made it really clear to
myself these are the only five things
i'm doing throughout the day
as a result of making it super clear and
conscious to myself that i was only
going to do five things i have been more
productive i have created more have been
more intuitive i have been more inspired
and i've been more creative you have to
wake up to the reality folks that you're
all a bunch of weak and vulnerable
people when it comes to what's outside
there the sky is literally falling
reports from australia have come in that
everybody that walked outside their
survival shelter was literally crushed
by the sky as it came down upon them the
once beautiful and green hills of the
countryside have become a barren
wasteland not to mention a band of
unruly sorcerers and bewitched the land
there are even reports of animals taking
up arms walking on two legs be afraid
everyone this is something we could
never anticipate it is my job to keep
you informed of all the latest horrible
things going on out there i'm just
trying to protect you
i can't take any more of this i can't i
can't watch this anymore
no more water
no more food
how am i going to survive in here
but i can't go out there
i can't survive in here
i can't survive out there
what am i gonna do
meet bruce lipton portrait of a man
paralyzed by fear
the lowly cellular biologist has been
hiding away in his survival shelter for
more days than he can count
and the apparent terror that reigns
outside the doors of his rusty
presents a limitless degree of terror in
his mind
however
there is one problem that takes center
stage on this inauspicious day
bruce has run out of food and water
the question of how to survive in a
state of chronic protection
lingers ever so greatly
what you are about to witness is a
strange sort of mortal combat between a
man
and his beliefs
in the twilight zone
you are entering a new reality of mind
unlock your potential with the key of
imagination
a realm of ever-changing perceptions
a world of quantum physics
beliefs and miracles
you have just crossed over
into the twilight zone
[Music]
i've got no more water and i've got no
more food
i can't survive by staying in protection
in order to survive i have to go out
because i can grow on the outside
and i can't go out there
because there's so many scary things out
there that can threaten my life but
wait a minute
it was in quantum physics
yes quantum physics the most valid
science on this planet
ah
here it
is consciousness
is creating our life experiences
wow
i have to have a different consciousness
i can't be afraid because the stress
shuts off my immune system
and the stress shuts down my growth and
maintenance of my body i have to change
that consciousness i can't be in fear
i have to recognize how powerful i am
i am a co-creator of the world
i am strong i am healthy i have to
maintain this as a way of life a belief
system before i go out there
but now that i'm aware
i no longer fear
going out there
[Music]
the world can often present us with a
frightening reality but sometimes the
fear we experience only exists in our
minds and now for bruce
fear only exists
in the twilight zone being a biologist i
want to talk about a different aspect of
service but it's the same thing because
my dear friend savage was talking about
service and how we can influence the
world around us i want to give you an
interesting biological insight about
your own personal consequence of being
in service
and basically
it has to do with the dna in your cells
i say what does that mean i say well
the dna is the genetic code
i say and every time the cell divides
you have to copy that code
and so if i can try to make an image
with my hand here imagine my arm is the
dna
and i say it's time to copy it
there's a protein so let's say the
microphone okay thank you
that my arm my hand is the copying
device it's like a train on a railroad
track
as the train moves down the dna it
leaves behind a copy of the dna it just
rode over
i say well that's really cool except
guess what when the train gets to the
end of the dna
it can't copy the part where the train
is sitting on it so it copied everything
all the way up to here but can't copy
this piece so when i copy it the new
piece is shorter than the original piece
and so every time you copy every time
the cell divides the dna gets a little
shorter than it did before and i say
well why is this relevant
because if you make a shorter piece of
dna when you copy it then every time
you're copying it you're interfering
with the genetic code
so it's like well nature would say oh my
god if every time the cell divides
pretty soon i'll chop that dna up and
i'll have a problem
but nature of course being
quite intelligent adds a piece of dna at
the end that it's not the gene it's just
an extension it's called a telomere you
may have heard the word telomere and i
say what is it it's extra railroad track
but it's not the genes and i say why is
it relevant because every time i copy it
i lose a piece of the telomere but i
didn't cut into the genes
and i said well what's aging all about
and here's what we now know aging
depression and disease
result when you copy the dna so many
times that you run out of that track of
telomere and the next time you copy
you're cutting off the gene which
interferes with your biology
so originally it was thought oh the
telomeres have a fixed length and every
time it divides you lose a piece of the
length and the scientists back in the
60s leonard hey flick calculated how
many times can a cell divide before it
runs out of telomere and it came out oh
it was about 50 to 60 cell divisions i
say well why is that relevant because
our stem cells which keep us alive
when they keep dividing what happens
after your stem cells went through 50
cell divisions now your stem cells won't
work anymore and now you can't replace
your cells in your body and that's when
they said oh humans have a given
lifetime you know 90
100 years at max
and that's your lifetime because that's
when you run out of telomeres
that was very depressing
because it says oh my god if i'm under
stress i actually cut the telomeres even
faster the more stress you're under the
more they disappears
now and it was because of again a woman
scientist because they always come up
with the neat stuff that the men are not
looking at
a woman scientist found there was an
enzyme
an enzyme called telomerase
telo
enzyme telomerase and i said what's that
enzyme it adds the length of the
telomere so as the cells are dividing if
you can activate this enzyme
it will extend the telomeres so the
cells have a relatively unlimited
lifespan
and so the relevance is the belief that
we only live 100 years is mainly a
consequence of not being able to
continue to extend the telomeres in a
normal person
so they start to find out well what
influences the telomere
well the biggest thing is lack of love
if you don't if you have a lack of love
the feedback will shut off the
telomerase enzyme
if
you have stress in your life
stress shuts off the enzyme
if you have no gratitude
or
appreciation of life it shuts off the
enzyme why well if you don't like life
then why give you an extra life that's
the enzyme is just responding
but now it comes down to the opposites
of those
love
and self-love which is most critical
is one of the the big drivers of
telomerase
gratitude
and joy of being in this world enhances
the enzyme why if you love the world you
want more and the cells will give you
more
but now in a beautiful question
the most important contributor to
telomerase activity is service
that you are doing something on this
planet you have a mission to do
something and that your nervous system
is telling yourselves i'm not ready to
go i have a job to do
and caregivers for example live an
extraordinarily longer healthier life
than other people why a caregiver's
mentality is i have to service and help
these people and therefore i cannot
leave yet and i have to be healthy
the feedback from the nervous system to
the cells activates telomerase so the
simple line is this
if we have a mission
and we have something to do on this
planet
you will activate telomerase service is
one of the primary things so it says if
you're just meandering through the earth
nice you're going to end around 90.
but if you're in service to the world
you can extend your life and right now
biologists somewhat agree that our
minimum
lifespan is a hundred and forty years
everybody's mind is like a tuning fork
because actually you can read brain
activity from outside your head with a
new thing called magnetoencephalograph
most people are familiar
electroencephalograph put wires on your
head and read your brain function the
new one magnetoencephalograph they put a
probe out here
and they can read your brain function
from outside well it's a very important
point it says well if you're reading my
brain function from outside then what am
i doing i must be broadcasting my brain
function so all of us are like tuning
forks but if we're all out of tune
then there's a tendency for even a
tuning fork that tries to stay in tune
will be pushed out of tune by something
we call entrainment and the issue is
how can you survive in this world the
answer is you must essentially detach
yourself from this field around you not
be taken in by the stories not be buy
into the fear not to buy into the
threats on our existence to start to
recognize look we are creating these
lives if you buy other people's creation
then you manifest what they're creating
if you want what you want then you have
to not get engaged and the more
conscious you become
the less you are affected by the outside
fields and so this rising consciousness
that we're seeing is the evolution of
humanity to rise above the noise of the
background and recognize you're the
creator i don't care how much knowledge
is in your head if that knowledge
doesn't go into your subconscious your
life will stay exactly the same as it
was you can be the brightest smartest
academic and i say fine did it change
your life and the answer is no
you have to take the knowledge that you
are walking within your conscious mind
and put that knowledge into your
subconscious programming
and when you do that
you are all powerful in the creation of
your own life and so just walking around
and being able to recite all these
wonderful sayings and things that you
hear from all the wonderful teachers
that we have and you say oh yes i
remember that that's a good quote that's
a nice quote oh that's a wonderful
saying
it's irrelevant
until that saying becomes part of your
program because now you are living from
the saying and not talking about the
saying
and that was the total transformation of
a life that on an academic level was
successful on a personal level i don't
even want to talk about that
but it changed everything why
because instead of having to chase
after life
after this understanding
things came to me the light will bring
it to you
the only thing that's in your way of the
light is a block in your belief that
other people have put into your
programming
you take your knowledge that you have
make it your subconscious program and
you will manifest all of the wonderful
spiritual wisdom that you have heard
throughout your whole life is not words
now
it is life and behavior and that's our
destination medical science has revealed
that from one-third to two-thirds which
is significant of all healing whether
it's drug related or surgery or whatever
healing process the healing didn't come
about from the process the healing came
about because the person believed the
process was going to heal them so if i
give you this brand new drug and it's
purple color because that makes it
really special you know
and it's funny because there is a drug a
purple drug and they said it's purple
and everybody's like oh wow that's got
to be special but people believe that
the drug holds this effect
and you give the person this drug
and all of a sudden they heal themselves
and they say yeah the drug did it and
then you tell them later but it was just
a sugar pill uh that that healing didn't
come from the drug it came from the
belief in the drug so
the belief in healing
the mind again doesn't it yeah it's
again the power of belief in this case
it's a very positive belief that this
procedure drug or whatever is going to
heal me but what people haven't talked
about because everyone knows about the
placebo effect is that
the placebo effect is based on a
positive thinking
what is the consequence of negative
thinking ah well science has a term for
it but it hasn't really come out in the
public it's called the nocebo effect and
the nocebo effect has been revealed by
science that a negative thought can not
only make you ill but a negative thought
could also kill you you can be scared to
death in us in a real sense okay uh and
and why is that important because it
turns out it's not just the positive
thought of a placebo that's influential
the negative thought works the same way
with the same power but in the opposite
direction so basically it's not placebo
no sibo
it comes down simply this it's the power
of thought
and a positive thought will move you in
a healing direction and a negative
thought will move you into an illness
direction
but before i get off that topic i don't
want people to go out there in the
audience and go oh oh one of those
positive thinking kind of guys it's like
it's more than just positive thinking
it's a commitment and an intention of
positive thinking it also really needs
the support of your subconscious belief
because if your subconscious belief is
going oh that new age weirdos stuff if
that's what your subconscious is
programmed to believe and yet your
conscious mind is the one that says i
will think positive thoughts and i go
back to the data only five percent of
your life is coming from the conscious
mind so if you're only entertaining a
positive thought with your conscious
mind you're only contributing five
percent of that to your life 95 of your
life is still coming from the
subconscious and if the subconscious
doesn't hold those beliefs
then you're actually fighting yourself
and not likely to realize the expression
of a positive thought everything you do
in your life you put out energy for
therefore start to review what you're
doing in your life because if you're
putting your energy into things you
cannot change in this world that is
exactly the same as writing a check and
just throwing away your money to the
outside because you get nothing back
from it so think about this very
interesting reality that you have this
energy checkbook and every time you use
energy you have to say is the use of
this energy
going to enhance my life or is it just
wasted energy am i getting involved in a
in a political argument with people
where i'm going to use up all my energy
and will i have changed the world no
am i going to use up all my energy to
try to convince other people to change
their life or change their way of living
to make them even healthier and they're
not ready to do that i'd be wasting my
energy
so here's an interesting thought
if i gave you an energy checkbook and
asked you to write a check every time
you had to have a thought you would have
to then ask yourself is is this thought
going to enhance my life or is this
thought going to take away from my life
and then when you start to realize that
you start to direct your actions where
you put your energy into things that
enhance your life and give you an
opportunity to survive and to go beyond
survival and really into thriving
so the point is this we are facing some
rough times the more thoughts you put
into the negative aspect the more
thoughts you put into the fear not only
are you just wasting your energy but as
in the biology belief these negative
thoughts these negative stresses
actually impair your immune system and
bring on disease itself
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to manifest success into your life
with dr joe dispenza check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there someone the other day
the day where you end your day and feel
complete because you finished all your
work you'll never have that you know
there's always more emails and more
things to check right so the demand has